the last time I had the dream I was I
was walking down the school
[Music]
hallway and then I see Butters and he's
like hey Eric you want to see what my
mom packed me for lunch and that's when
I start to notice that something's round
everyone I cared about has been
systematically replaced and finally I
want to scream and I'm like why are they
replacing every single character with
someone who is diverse but then Kenny's
like it's not our fault it's cuz of
Kathleen Kennedy but then Kathleen
kenned is just like it make it more lame
and everyone in town is like no please
Kathleen Kennedy stop rud and everything
for Kathy Kennedy is all like put
another gay divers woman in it make it
more lame and the Disney stock just
keeps going down and down and down and
the bober is all like no it's going with
my no make it more lame that is exactly
what they're doing and that is why we
hate the diversity equity and inclusion
casting and writing in movies